allem einnahmen zu kommen meine lieben
freund nicht ob ich heute recht herzlich
willkommen beiden seiner neuen episoden
vor das video startet habe ich erst mal
eine ganz kurze frage an euch und zwar
wirklich man eigentlich diesen rudi
herbst der minister von de kommen nun
allerdings zum wirklich wichtigen meine
lieben freunde denn ich denke heute
aufbauen zieht immer wieder einige leute
unserer heute mit einem schild hier
steht daraufhin kurz packen komme gleich
wieder und dieses schild werde ich jetzt
hier im tv screen einfach mal so stehen
lassen und ich schauen wir uns mit ihren
reaktionen an
wenn kurz so
[Musik]
aber ich war drauf die lupe
das sei nicht so nummer 1 regel was wir
nicht machen sollte der doku vertrauen
auf einfach dass mich irgendjemand nicht
weg drückt den tod tausender kommen
kommen kurz packen kommen gleich
[Musik]
ich habe extra spiegelverkehrt
aufgestiegen weil ich dachte das ist da
schon im verkehr angezeigt
deswegen habe ich alle weggedrückt
konnten das einfach nicht lesen zwei
stunden später
jetzt ist es hier halt spiegelverkehrt
aber ich glaube dass es bei den leuten
jetzt richtig homola
[Musik]
hinter states
ist das weil ich dann nicht vom bild bin
und dass der denkt dass dass sie
irgendwie so ein
china denkt ihr dass sie irgendwie zum
standbild ist und dann verknüpft er mich
nicht mehr mit anderen leuten oder was
der grund ja ja ja ja ja
[Musik]
hallo würdigung attacken
ja also ich war grad auf club einfach
[Musik]
oder
also ich habe extra so ein schild
hingestellt ganz dringend ich habe heute
schon relativ viel gegessen deswegen ok
lieferbar gut freut mich hat sich dein
licht grad verändert ja was ich habe
hier ganze schalter hier corona party in
einem club
[Musik]
ja mei das ist richtig das ist richtig
dass andere wahrheit
das hier ist falsch ja natürlich jetzt
einfach beide hin
ich bin kurz packen
[Musik]
daraus wird
so eine safe sondern weißt du
[Musik]
ich habe heute schon relativ viel
gegessen dann musste ich kurz aufs klo
ja soll ich muss noch hände waschen uns
das alles ist ein bisschen stressig
gerade aber wollte er die noch mehr für
eure kämen geht sagen so krank wieder
ist die aus sandra ich rufe seiner kurz
an wenn es für dich okay ist hat ja
schon gesehen meinte er ich glaube es
geht nicht an ihre den sekunden später
erklären warum bist du nicht angegangen
wir waren mädel beim tvd meinte sie sah
aus wie du aber war sie nicht
diese personengruppen kurz karten kommen
gleich wieder
[Musik]
hallo
so soll ich sagen ich musste noch eine
box oder bisschen gedauert ich habe dich
schon mal getroffen aber du hast mich
einfach weiter es gibt das kann nicht
sein aber ich hoffe dann vor so gemacht
noch ich habe mich ganz kurz was ist ein
schlechter tag für ein gebot tag der
offenen tür dafür sehr sonnen schlechter
witz hallo ich wurde gerade aus was ich
wurde gerade weg es gibt von mädels und
jetzt bin ich bei euch
ich mache eigentlich gerade sondern wie
die krank machen wo ich hierhin schreibe
bin kurz gucken kommen wir gleich wieder
dann komme ich erst nach einer minute
ins bild und jetzt habe ich halt dann
konnte ich derzeit nicht weggehen also
stetig gen kurz weg und dann kommen auch
wieder okay
[Musik]
ich war gleich wieder ist da nur das ist
so
nein ich weiß wer erstes lukas ist luca
hat es auch die gleiche gleichzeitig
ihren ran
und er hat er schreibt auch makaken und
so das ist fakt pro mädels musste kraft
foods packen gehen
sorry dass ich jetzt hier warten lassen
[Musik]
ich habe mir so ein up gelangt alter
warum sagt ihr denn luca schreibt immer
kacken die haut rein das war gutes ende
waren nicht meine lieben freunde sagen
die einfachste ja dass luca er schreibt
auch immer kacken strecke allerdings
gefallen hat meine lieben freunde dann
das gern einen daumen hoch unter wir
hier da schreibt immer unten die
kommentare was ich meinem nächsten raum
sowie video machen soll und wenn euch
das video besonders gut gefallen hat
dann schickt eure freunde in whatsapp
gemacht dass man unter tel
ich gehe wirklich packen
[Musik]